here's the thing about him he was a bit
of a bugger about things
and his favorite phrase to me was did i
tell you about
and every time he did that i would just
roll my eyes and go
go and he'd start telling me something
and i'd look at him and go
no you buggy you haven't and you know
i've written the screenplay you know
we've got a producer and director
working on it now he was saying that
right up to two or three days before he
died he would continuously say
did i tell you about because he'd
suddenly remember something else
we'd want to embellish or enhance
something that he'd read in the script
who knows how much more he went to his
grave with
many of the listeners will be familiar
with your story
but can you tell us how you came to
write the tattooist of auschwitz
oh absolutely because it's one of those
crazy things that uh
anyone in life can look for
and i guess the lesson here is when
somebody asks you to do something unless
you've got a damn good reason
for not doing it then say yes and and
i've learned that particularly
from what happened with me and nully
because i was having a
well a coffee with a friend who i hadn't
seen for many months i'd been putting it
off
and while we were casually having that
cup of coffee one sunday afternoon
she just casually said to me i have a
friend whose mother has just died
and his father has asked him to find
somebody he can tell a story too
that person can't be jewish you're not
jewish do you want to meet him
i said what's the story and she said i
don't know and i said oh okay then i'd
love to
so from having a cup of coffee and
saying yes to that and then saying yes
to meeting a stranger
the tattooist of auschwitz came about so
what happened next
well a week later because that was a
sunday and i worked full-time
this was like 2004 was it two three
the end of 2003 and
yeah well a week later the following
sunday i knocked on the apartment door
of lolly sokolov
and he opened it and he had a dog either
side of him
one of them was well she was bigger than
about the size of an average small pony
and the other one was smaller than my
cat
and he didn't even look at me he just
opened the door and muttered the word
come
and he and the doggies turned around and
disappeared
so i followed them in and he just walked
into a room at
a lounge dining room and he just pointed
to the table and went sit
and pointed to a chair so i sat
and he and the doggies disappeared again
i'm getting a little bit unnerved here
as you can imagine but a few minutes
later all three of them reappeared
with bloody bringing me the first of
many many
bad cups of coffee you didn't make a
good coffee
never i was so grateful when our
relationship got to the
um point where you know we were now
friends and i could say to them
hey how about we go out for coffee
anything to be able to love
god please stop making me your coffee uh
so what's the writing process like
obviously you have this
very very emotional story i imagine for
him to try and get out it's a long time
ago
it took a long while for you to fully
eke out the entire
narrative right oh absolutely
you've got to remember this is a man you
know 87 years of age and
he was grieving the loss of his wife and
just wanted to be with her
he wanted to tell a story and i didn't
know for
many many weeks months probably whether
or not there was actually a story there
that could be strung out because he kept
going over the same thing
he would never finish a storyline or a
vignette he was telling
and i knew from my work
that and when you're talking to people
elderly people in particular
and people who are traumatized that
the only thing you can do to hear their
story
is to listen i had no pen and paper in
front of me i'm not writing anything
down
i've got no recording device nothing to
distract him
and that was what i i had to do and
that's why it sort of took those many
many weeks
of me racing home and trying to
frantically write down and phonetically
writing these german words that i've
never heard of
i mean when he keeps talking about
himself being the tatavira and i'm
sitting there going
what the heck's a tatter bella until i
could find some
spelling resembling that word and
translate it
so yes it was a challenge you were
working in your memory quite hard then
well yes but here's the thing and you
know that this is what plays out in the
book that
um is being released tomorrow in my as
far as i'm concerned
because tomorrow's still going to be
thursday for me
it was because where i worked
and from past experiences i knew that if
you
actively listen to somebody you listen
to them
without thinking in your head or what
can i jump in and say here
what's my true bob's worth how should i
respond
that when you're doing that you're
actually not hearing everything that's
being said
and so i did have my brain through my
work
trained to just actually be in the
moment with with people
what was your work then before you were
now obviously a famous novelist
well for 20 years i worked in the social
work department at a major hospital here
in melbourne
so every day i was talking to patients
friends relatives carers
of people who were there and many of
them
woke up that morning not knowing that
they were going to end up in an acute
hospital
or their family members didn't so always
through periods of tragedy and trauma
and under those circumstances if you
don't help them
in any way even if you're not you have
to learn to listen
and you don't write notes and i guess
that paid dividends when it came to
sitting down with
someone how lucid at 87 can you be was
there a lot of listening to the same
story over and over did you hear the
same tale a few times it's a shame
obviously that you couldn't sit down and
it was
perfectly chronological here's what you
need to know from start to finish i
imagine it bounced around a lot
there was none of that uh quite the
opposite and you're quite right
he would start telling one story and
this is how i knew
that there was so much more to be got
from him because he'd start
often to say something and then he'd put
his head down again and he'd shake his
head and
i could see him getting distressed which
told me that what he
was now remembering and thinking about
was very very painful
and and i never pushed him i just had to
wait till
i saw an opening and i decided that
opening for me with him
was to invite him home to meet my family
and how else can this man ever trust me
if he doesn't know me
so by having him meet and get along with
my husband and three adult children and
openly flirt with the young adult
daughter
he was an absolute sod um
but that's fine that's how the lolly of
old started coming back
by being introduced to this yeah young
sort of 18 19 year old
potty as he called her
but um yeah and because they then shared
secrets about me
and so he now had the goods on me and
then knowing about
parts of my life it gave him that
freedom to
to now trust me and feel that he could
talk to me and
that's when it all changed and he now
openly went in front of me and with me
as he
did recall and remember the evil and the
horror
and all those amazing story lines that
he had survived
it's an interesting point that being
vulnerable to someone
is one of the biggest bonding
experiences that you can go through a
lot of the time
i think um especially when perhaps when
we're younger especially if you're a guy
you presume that you bond over like
shared masculinity
you know kind of sheds shared strength
uh like you're
you're you're courageous i'm courageous
you're brave i'm brave but actually what
really really forms a friendship is
showing
telling someone something which in the
wrong hands would be catastrophic to you
because it shows that you have faith and
trust in them
exactly and he had to get to that point
as much as he wanted to tell his story
he was only ever going to tell a very
clinical factual story
if if i hadn't have persevered and won
over his friendship
and yes somebody else may have written
his story and i love it when i talk to
journalists and they
say well that's not the approach i would
have taken i said
i'm not sure you would have invested
three years of your life in him
not that i see it that way quite the
opposite
we were friends and after i got his
story out down and
i'd produced a draft of a screenplay
which is how i wrote it initially
um and he was sort of reading that and
proving that we were just going out
because
he he started living again which i guess
happens after you've lost your partner
uh he stopped saying i need to be with
guitar
and he then was asking me to go out with
him
while he reconnected with the jewish
community that he pulled away from
and then all of a sudden i found myself
going out as his date
and him introducing me as his girlfriend
and uh sending me off to go and join the
ladies and
and we then had this amazing friendship
of
uh social occasions with anywhere
between six
to 200 members of the jewish community
coffee shop gatherings movies um
yeah that became our life and he had to
joke with my husband
she may be your wife but she's my
girlfriend you know and steve would go
yeah yeah okay you wanna you can have
her
that's great um when did he pass
on the 31st of october 2006
three years later wow so that was
i'm gonna guess you were you needed all
of that time
all of the remainder of his life really
to get the story out of him
not really here's the thing about him he
was a bit of a bugger about things
and his favorite phrase to me was did i
tell you about
and every time he did that i would just
roll my eyes and go
go and he'd start telling me something
and i'd look at him and go no you buggy
you haven't
and you know i've written the screenplay
you know we've got a producer and
director working on it
now he was saying that right up to
two or three days before he died he
would continuously say
did i tell you about because he'd
suddenly remember something else
we'd want to embellish or enhance
something
that he'd read in the script yeah
gosh who knows how much more he went to
his grave with
precisely what do you think he would
have thought if he saw the
state of what happened in 2018 when
the the novel came out well you wouldn't
be talking to me you'd be talking to him
because he would be wanting to be the
person out there
talking up his story that's just who he
was you reckon he'd be a good podcast
guest
oh yeah absolutely
but look he was utterly utterly charming
and
he got him talking he he didn't really
shut up
and you might occasionally be able to go
yeah well can i just
ask you this and he'd go don't interrupt
but
he would be loving it and he would want
to be center stage and i'd be pushed
into the background somewhere and he'd
just drag me up as his girlfriend
you know not the writer of his story
that's amazing
and final thing i wanted to touch on
from this upon reading and doing a
little bit of sort of
um extra research the survivor guilt
seems to be a real strong theme for
everyone all of the little survivor
stories that i've come across
um can you talk a little bit about what
you found during your
your discussions with him to do with the
survivor guilt for the prisoners of
auschwitz and i guess all of the other
concentration camps
oh absolutely and the many many
survivors i've spoken to you know the
ones in melbourne who he introduced me
to
and i think australia got the second or
third largest number of holocaust
survivors
outside of israel um and so i
privileged to meet hundreds of them here
not too many of them
are still living one very special lady
still is
and they all exhibited what i would say
and i'm no clinician
i'm no expert here but just through
talking to them
that every single one of them had a
degree of survival guilt
how could they not and talking to their
family members that that actually was
always confirmed and borne out by
talking to their children or their adult
grandchildren
it was a matter of um did it they'll
stop you
living the best life you could now with
lolli
and giza it didn't stop them because the
day they got married
they made a promise to each other that
the only way
that they could honor all of those
people who did not survive
was to have the best life they could no
good
he said would come of us not having the
best life we could
and so i met many others like him and
there's two particular ladies in israel
right now who i'm very very attached to
who's going to be they're going to be my
next story they're 94 and 96
and um yes they did that same thing they
got on and had the best life they could
but then i also met so many who have
struggled
and that survivor guilt it's been proven
that it actually can get passed down
through genetics and to children and
even to grandchildren
there's some fascinating research being
done on that
and and i've i guess once again i've
seen
children of these survivors you know now
adults
with children and grandchildren of their
own and even they
know that they are carrying that trauma
it's bizarre the way that this nature
and nurture combines
final thing actually i promise we're
going to get into stories i hope which
is a new book
in a second i'm going to guess you'll
have read man's search for meaning by
viktor frankl
yes yeah what was there anything upon
reading that which is
i guess one of the other very famous
insights into
that world was there anything um extra
that was illuminated everyone that's
listening will know that i'm a massive
fan of that book
um upon reading that did you start to
draw any threads that you hadn't before
oh absolutely same with our premier
leavey's book too
you know night in particular and yet
so the storylines are different but the
same
and that's the whole thing about us
holocaust survivors i think or any
survivor from any kind of
evil or a horrific period in history
that even this i met survivors who said
to me
a couple we also met in birkenau
and they each had their own version of
their life
there as well and that's why i think
i've been so delighted with how the
jewish community
all around the world from from here to
the europe to
south africa canada the states
how every person in that community
everyone's been touched every jewish
person's been touched by the holocaust
and they all want to say to me thank you
for recognising that there's an
individualism about surviving
that it is wonderful that the historians
and academics have told
the story of the holocaust for decades
but uh hearing just the one story be
invictus be
lollies um be it suckers whoever
you can relate to the one
and see the common threads and then
their own individual
survivor skills are you familiar with
some of the studies that have been done
on how um
humans are affected by altruism requests
so there is a um really
unfortunate effect that everyone
appears to fall prey to if you are to
show an advert for
one particular a unicef or a support
africa starving children advert
and you have a single uh girl
there the impact if you have the girl
and her brother or the girl in her
family or the girl in her village
decreases so people donate
less the more um it's a little bit like
i guess the
called the witness uh that uh witness
effect where you all think that someone
else is gonna ring
i think it kind of starts to dissolve
down the story so you're totally correct
obviously the the numbers of the the
holocaust are
absolutely astronomical and and terrible
but it doesn't drive a learning point
home in the same way that a single
narrative does because
you can't you can't learn to love 4
million 10 million
20 million people but you can learn you
can learn to love one character right
absolutely and look it's been born out
to me a couple of times uh with regard
to that
here's a story that someone sent me a
clipping from a newspaper in the states
and
i think it's a few years old but a
gentleman in new york a jewish gentleman
he got obsessed with trying to work out
what six million of something would look
like
because that's the the figure that they
say
six million jewish men women boys and
girls uh
died and he started collecting paper
clips
and he well he drove his wife out of the
house because he started making a pile
in his living
room and he collected six million paper
clips
and he apparently then looked at them
and he reached in and he just plucked
out one
and he said this is the only one that
matters
because he could not comprehend or
relate to that huge
pile i think there's something
for a lot of us to to learn there about
the the fundamentals of human nature
especially if we want to have impact
with people um a lot of the time
objective measures of success that you
see instagram followers book sales
money um that sounds on the surface of
things great but
as you've identified there and and the
studies that i've just brought up
show that doesn't impact in the same way
as going very very deep and narrow
so moving on to the next book the new
one stories of hope
why have you why have you written this
and how does it relate to
your first novel well after
a year of lolly's book being out and
traveling around the people i was
talking to are still coming to hear me
talk
he had this this kind of stool um
overwhelms me and i sort of struggle a
lot but
you really want to come hear me chat you
were here last year when i was here
and it's wonderful but of course so
many people now have read the book so
when i'm now going and putting up in
front of
a 100 500 whatever number of people that
are in the room with me um they actually
want to have
me talk about the book they want me to
tell them about my time with lolly
they want to hear the bits about lolly
that are not in the book
and she said that was one reason but the
other
main reason that stories of hope has
come about
was really from day one virtually of the
book coming out
i have received thousands of emails from
people all around the world
now these i'm terrible i've read a lot
of books
because i've been around a long time and
i have never written to an author
so i'm feeling really bad about that and
i think maybe i should do that
so um michael conley uh david baldacci
is
however they weren't just writing and
thanking me
for the book and saying how much they
enjoyed it
so many of them were sharing something
very
deeply personal painful traumatic about
their own lives
and saying that from reading about lolli
and gita and silke
they found a sense of hope that they
actually now
could overcome or start to walk work
towards overcoming
this tragedy that was in their lives and
i'm talking about thousands of these
absolutely thousands chris and
some of them are just incredible to know
that somebody is
going to attempt to continue carrying on
after she had given up hope having seen
her brother being collateral damage in a
drive-by shooting
a young man second year of university
was everything to live for why
why did this happen to him the couple
who have been trying for years and years
to have a baby and finally have a baby
that then
dies 16 days later this is the kind of
lettering email i get the 50 plus year
old woman in germany
who had just found out her grandfather
had been the
engineer who had designed and built the
gas chambers in auschwitz
and felt she had no right to continue to
live
without being her background so when you
start getting these
stories and of course i write back to
the ones that are really really personal
um i have to unfortunately rely on my
manager to write back to a lot of the
others and say hey this ridge or
your letter because i read them all and
respond
and so in talking about that and then
when silke came out or was coming out
i was in koshita in slovakia doing some
research
for finishing off silker's book and i
was there with
my publisher from london margaret my
picture from london off we went to
cauchita
and we'd spent a couple of days talking
to these amazing friends and neighbours
of silkers
and finding out now once again talking
listening listening
hearing about this amazing woman and
a couple of days i think it was maybe on
day three and
that night margaret and i we had dinner
in the restaurant in the hotel and we
had a drink of wine or two and then
somebody pointed out there was this
downstairs bar
and so the two of us found ourselves
wandering down into this dungeon of a
bar in this
um yeah average hotel in kosciuta
and when you're over a few drinks i
think she said we'd progress to the port
at that stage i'd get a bit vague then
but um she started we started she
started asking me about she said like
she'd been observing me okay because
she's now was with me while i'm talking
to people
and it's not the same by the way when
you have to do it with translators too
you get your head's going in all
directions and she said
i was watching you listening she said it
really is something else
she said have you always been able to
just listen and focus on the person
talking to you
and i went well not really i said nobody
listened to me at home
when i was growing up i said oh with the
exception of this one person in my life
my great-grandfather and we started
talking about
that and i was just telling her and i
wrote it right about in my book
how this old man who was well into his
sort of 80s
at that point when i was 10 11 12 years
of age how he taught me
to listen and he used that word listen
to me
listen to nothing listen to yourself
and so i had several years with this
amazing man and from that
she said oh i think we can do something
here how about we take a little break
from
historical fiction and throw in stories
of hope
what's the outcome what do you want uh
people to get from stories of hope
if there was something that people would
take away like a single lesson
what would it be that it's never too
late
to start listening and
how you do that is actually not that
difficult
and i give a few clues particularly if
it's like listening to your elders
and that was the other thing that so
many people were saying to me
i wish i'd asked my dad or my granddad
to tell me about his life and i was
hearing so much regret
from people who had had a an elderly
person in their life that they'd never
bothered to sit down and get this story
from
and and i think that's quite sad to have
that regret
um look i've got it too i probably
didn't listen to my dad
or ask my dad enough to tell me about
him
and so there was that and the people who
were saying to me how can i get
my grandfather my mother whatever to
talk to me
there was no double whammy thing i love
this uh i love this quote from
the book listen to your elders advice
not because they are right but because
they have more experience of being wrong
awesome exactly exactly
yeah they've made the mistakes you don't
have to learn from them and i think
that's the other important thing
you by the way you do get to make your
own mistakes and
that that's something that as a parent i
rammed home to my kids
no i'm happy to talk to you and we'll
chat about things but
you get to make your own mistakes you're
not gonna lead your life
off mine and um and if you've read the
book you know that i
too made a very serious mistake only 12
months ago
with my daughter and and her newborn
baby
and that just goes to show that yeah we
all make mistakes
it's try and pick up on it quickly
and that could have had quite dire
consequences yeah it did actually
for a period and i'm very very
proud that she and her husband agreed
for me to write this
storyline and i've already had a couple
of
interviewers like yourself uh two women
in particular who have said to me
you have no idea what reading that story
about postnatal depression
meant to me i had a sister i had
a friend a similar thing we didn't know
how to cope
the elders point i think is really
interesting
um because in this new
21st century youtube podcaster verse
that we're in and obviously i'm
contributing to that problem myself by
providing this content
um in the past
um our evolutionary history
our elders would have been the ones who
had acquired wisdom right they would
have been the ones that we would have
turned to
um and i think that that's certainly
been forgotten in
the 21st century because the gateway
to information access all of the
friction's been removed
i can access anything i want instantly
online i don't need to go to my granddad
i don't need to go to the tribe leader
or the shaman or whoever it might be
i don't have to go to them and
conversely
you have more liquid intelligence um a
little bit younger your crystallized
intelligence continues to rise as you
get older
but your sorry fluid intelligence peaks
around about 21 so you think well
the quickest learners in the world are
these chess grand masters who are you
know
young age so i should just focus on the
rapid
access and digesting of information at
that young age
which kind of casts off the wisdom of
the old but as you've said there
you don't necessarily need to be taught
how to do something
it's how not to do something which can
be just as informative
oh absolutely um and
most people will have an older person in
their life even if it's just a neighbor
they love talking it's one thing i have
learned is that they're
hungry for someone to listen to them i
can't help but think that as we come out
of
the pandemic that there have been so
many elderly people who have been
totally alone for months
i'm not asking everybody in the street
to go and find their neighbor and sit
down and chat to them
but you know it wouldn't hurt you and
even if you don't learn something you
know you are giving back now there is
nothing more rewarding than actually
giving you don't have to be receiving
even
your any wisdom any advice uh
it's i kind of get a bit upset that some
people just think that i'm just an
ordinary person and i haven't had a
remarkable life
well to me there is no such person in
existence
everybody uh has got something about
them
that is remarkable because it's the
unique it's them
but you just don't know it and like
lolly he just kept
he would just say but i was just an
ordinary man and i went yeah but you
were living in a pretty extraordinary
time
that's the and the bizarre thing about
all of all of our lives we feel
so mundane of clothes it's just familiar
to you right
exactly um and that's not the that's not
the reality really it may be yours
because
and hey maybe this is why we jump to the
next sort of chapter or i don't know how
many more it is
than listening to yourself and the
importance of doing that
because if you do learn to do that at a
deeper level than you're probably
doing um now because i don't think much
many of us listen to ourselves too well
unless you are into that kind of
spiritualism that
you do go and meditate and that doesn't
seem to be the norm amongst people i
know
they're they're beating themselves up um
they're not taking time out to just sit
down
and look at their own body their own
physiology how am i reacting
can i feel my blood pressure going up
they're not
having that just internal you know
conversation with themselves
it doesn't have to take long it can be
done quite quickly
do it in the damn shower that's enough i
know it's what i did a lot because
you're on your own there's nothing else
to do
and the other place that can actually
help you get into that state of being
relaxed and content i find um
is a pet that if you're hanging out with
your dog
that dog's not asking anything of you
and
i used the dogs of lollies to help me
when i was getting upset
because the two dogs always with us and
often when i was hearing something that
was really starting to you know get me
distressed and
i didn't want to shut him up because he
was on a roll i could just reach down
and i just stroke one of the dogs
struck one of the dogs um
and so i i think dogs and cats to a
lesser degree because cats will only let
you do it if they're in the mood
but um try listening to yourself a bit
more
yeah i think a lot of people struggle
with the fact that the
inner monologue that they have is not
very friendly
um the negative self-talk that we've
accumulated throughout our lives i put
in my newsletter this week there's a
lyric from a song that i love
called i wouldn't talk to a friend the
way that i talk to myself
and yeah sadly that's the way that a lot
of people's
inner monologues go that there if it was
a friend or another human
outside of you that was saying the
things that you say to yourself they'd
be your worst enemy
and you can't turn that off so it
doesn't surprise me that people
don't necessarily want to turn the
volume down
and this is where you see uh individuals
who can't bear to be alone
who are constantly need to be with
someone surrounded by a friend in a
group
um or substances alcohol drugs
whatever it might be because that
silence
starts to let them hear quieter voices
that they really don't like the sound of
and um if it really is that bad then
that they need to sort of get someone
who can help them with that but just to
be able to get to that point
where they realize that and that they
need some some help to
to shut that voice up and i also think
that the whole notion and
you know gosh i'm using it i'm talking
about social media
and facebook and i remember when it
first came out hearing
more friends of my children's boasting
about how many friends they had
on facebook and that whole notion of
what is a friend
and a friend is not some person that
you've never met but you decided to
say accept when they asked you to be
their friend on facebook
uh i think that sort of can be you know
very very well it can be quite damaging
for a lot of people to think that that's
the only outlet
they've got for a friend and i suspect
that things are going to be even tougher
in the next few months as we
come out of a covert and the
damage to the mental health of a lot of
people already we're seeing it here in
melbourne it's quite significant and
just in the last 24 hours
the police have shot a man because he
was having a mental health episode and
charged them with a knife
and they had no choice and even though
we're in lockdown here in melbourne
i'm in real lockdown at curfew can't
leave home
if you do it's for one hour maximum a
day
and that is just going to take a
terrible toll
i'm not sure that any book on whole
stories of hope
can make much of a difference
but um yeah all i can say is
if you've got a neighbor and look and
this is a funny thing and this is what
we're seeing here in melbourne
we went into lockdown and during that
first lockdown
everybody was out on the street
everybody was knocking on neighbors
doors
everybody was bonding together as a
community
it was fabulous to see and if the papers
in the media were full of all these
beautiful stories
of how we were putting together and then
we came out of it we got a little taste
of freedom
and then things went pear-shaped in
melbourne and so we got locked down
again hard
even harder than before but people are
not responding the same
they're going no no i've been there i've
done that i'm not i want to do it again
and now we're having riots we're having
people taking it to
the police who are trying to enforce
these very strict
rules and laws that have come into the
town and
very very different to the first time
they we really only had one shot we blew
it
i think that that's the the major
concern you can probably get people to
comply
to some discomfort once but getting them
to go back and and burn their hand a
second time you know once you put it on
the stove once you can put it chalk it
up as a right that's a lesson to be
learned
but then being mandated to go do it
again it kind of doesn't surprise
me going back to the book we've talked
about elders but also there's some
wisdom apparently in children now i have
not a massive amount of
experience with elders which i'm really
sad about most of my grandparents have
passed
which which is a real shame um but i
spend even less time
around young children there was a story
um that you pulled out
from your own life you said you didn't
want to grow up to be like the female
role models that you had in the 50s and
60s
your relationship with your mother and
grandmother seems really distinct
from the world that we see around us now
could you tell us a bit about that and
how that
upbringing shaped you oh absolutely
well there's two aspects to it and one
of us that i was growing up in a time
when
children were to be seen and not heard
and that
i was quite an observant little thing i
had four brothers and so i was on the
outer straight away
um the the females in my family my
mother my aunts and my grandmother and
we all lived in quite
close proximity in rural new zealand
they never ever spoke to me except to
yell at me grab me or tell me to do
something
there was never any conversation
yeah i've not really admitted this to
anyone else but my mother actually said
to me so many many times when i was
growing up
that she was sorry that she had me that
she was sorry that she'd had a girl
to her she could see no life other than
the one that she thought and found
herself trapped in
and that the boys were going to be fine
because they could go away
and then have a life and you know that
was a pretty tough thing to be
told for you know all your
impressionable years that
someone's sorry that put you on this
earth um
and my grandmother she was uh extreme
even more
so yeah i did not have that now here's
the thing about being a parent that that
i
took on board i looked at all the things
that
my parents had done to me and brought me
up if
though my brothers and i say we weren't
brought up we were dragged up
and looked at the few things that i
thought were okay
and then made sure that i would not
duplicate as a parent all those those
behaviors
that i thought hurt me and were not
productive whatsoever
you know my adult children accuse their
father and i
of now of not being tough enough on them
i mean you just can't win you're either
too damn tough as a parent or
and now i'm hearing from these adults in
their 30s and 40s you weren't tough
enough
you let us get away with too much and
i'm not going to let you know my kids do
that and i'll go oh
well you just take what you like from my
parenting
and uh reject the rest because that's
what we get to do
but yes i think mother-daughter
relationships are complex
uh the best of times um i'm really
really
proud to say that i don't think mine is
with my daughter
because i worked bloody hard to make
sure
that she did not have any of that
baggage
that i carried it did not transfer in
fact the first words i said to her when
she was about a minute old
and i held her and i looked at her and i
said you will never be a victim
and to me making sure that as a female
there was no victim mentality ever
allowed to creep into any of her
behavior
or anything she said and you can do that
really subtly she didn't know what i was
doing
but um the whole anytime as a child she
said other boy
because she had two older brothers of
course you know but the boys are doing
it why can't i is it because i'm a girl
no it's because they are significantly
older than you and they've hurt that
right of passage
but yeah when you listen to them um
listen to kids and what i'm enjoying now
listening to my grandkids
they are just delightful and the whole
notion which i talk about of
listen to the little things really
listen to them
when they say that um that their
brothers whacked them
uh yeah emphasize with her and say
you'll talk to them
but hear them and let them know they've
been heard
because you do not want them to become
teenagers and then not talk to you
that's the worst time that um they can
suddenly say well she didn't listen to
me all my life why should i start
telling her now my problems
when those problems now matter it's
really bizarre isn't it throughout the
1900s parents focused everything they
could
on getting children to walk and talk for
the first three years of life and then
sit down and shut up for the next 15.
pretty much pretty much you did not have
an opinion
or a thought or even a feeling which is
very sad
that there was just none of that well
look i can only talk about
me and that's all i ever talk about in
this book and i think right up front
i make it really clear guys i have got
no qualifications
but telling you anything all i can do
is tell you a bit about me and that
wasn't easy to do can i say
pretty much what did we say right back
at the beginning about the importance of
having the individual narrative
you know having the single story that is
the delivery mechanism
and it it it helps us
we live our lives in narratives you know
like we can think that with these
logical creatures
but for all of our history all of human
history stories were told through
mythology through archetypes
um that is the the beauty of the
storytelling art form which i think
in a world where 15 second tick tock
videos and
even hour-long podcasts this still
probably
isn't like an entire night spent around
the fire with the elders talking these
stories etc etc
um there's probably still room to be
moved on the
on the ceiling of long-form conversation
um
and yeah allowing people to immerse
themselves in stories like that i think
is
is really important oh absolutely it is
um is this show censored fire away
okay uh i love it when my publishers say
to me
um we think you've always been a
storyteller and i would say well that's
not the words my family used they called
me a [ __ ] artist
because i know that i did
talk and want to tell stories nobody
listened to them but
they just would you know excuse me of
talking about a [ __ ]
and living on a farm with cows you know
that was the appropriate phrase wasn't
it
but yeah because i actually love telling
stories and even if say half them are
made up
isn't that part of the the fun too
you can start out with a little pearl of
a storyline
and then you might not just embellish
the hell out of it and
see where you can go with it if you've
got somebody prepared to listen
you're obviously a budding novelist
weren't you so how can everyone that's
listening now be a better listener when
they leave this
podcast um first of all
recognize the difference between
listening to the person in front of you
for the purpose of responding or
uh are you actually wanting to hear what
they've got to say because
heads up guys if you're talking you're
actually not
learning anything you're just repeating
something you already know
and and to be able to distinguish
between oh
he's saying that and look his body
language is saying something as well
that there's more in the words and in
the body
and once you start doing it it's
actually incredibly rewarding
and it's not difficult it can come quite
easily
there will be times of course in the
majority of times when you're in
conversation a conversation is different
that's a to and fro thing
that's not really sharing of anything in
the way that
um somebody's wanting to tell you
something about themselves that whole
aspect of making yourself vulnerable
that you mentioned
and if somebody does that to you you
know you get to
feel really honoured and and respect it
for what it is
in terms of listening to other people
elders
what i found often works is to find an
object or something they've said
and hone in on that and if it's your
grandmother
and you've been visiting her for the
last 25 years every sunday
and everyone's been there and you've
never really sat down go back
and pick up something off your mental
piece you've been looking at it for all
your life
guarantee there's a reason that's
sitting there
and if you ask about something there's
you're in
so people are not going to just start
talking to you for the hell of it
you have to find an n the exception
being kids
kids are going to babble at your
non-stop you're going to have to just
sort of pick out what's in there
oh maybe i need to stop what i'm doing
and respond to that
and you're only going to do that 10 of
the time trust me
been there done that but you know what
10 percent is better than none at all
and and i think i mentioned in the book
watching my five-year-old
grandson you know yelling at his
three-year-old sister
um you're not listening right she
listened to me and i looked over
and there was little madam just turning
it back on him because he's wanting to
show her something and and
involve her and something and she's not
going to play ball
and he just was getting so upset until i
went over there and i sat down
and what's the problem reggie won't
listen to me he's five and that's the
word he uses
you're not listening already and so i
turned rachel around to make eye contact
with her
and just very simply said do you not
want to listen to nathan right now
and she said no i said do you think you
might want to listen to him later
might okay well why don't we negotiate
when's a good time for nathan to come
and talk to you and you'll listen
as simple as that 10 minutes later she
was listening
schedule slots in if you if you could
get the kids a
your manager see if your manager's got a
little bit of spare work capacity
maybe they can schedule in some some
time slots what's your availability to
speak and what's your of it and then
they could
put it on a calendar share share it on
google calendar or something like that
and then they'd be fine
that would be absolutely rick that's how
we did this so it makes sense to me
he talked about how to listen when
someone's going through or been through
trauma
is that a specialist type of listening
well yes and no once again it's
something very easy but
the other problem we have when we are
listening or when we're having a
conversation
is that we're hardwired not to like
silence
and when there's that person stop
speaking
the the need to jump in and get rid of
that silence that gosh
that's overpowering at times
sometimes and that's that's the whole
thing about listening to people in
traumatic or tragic circumstances
they say something and if you actually
do just shut up
for a little bit longer and just give
them that room to
formulate something else to say you'll
probably find that they do
and and it's knowing when to actually
then come in and
ask another question but more often than
not uh
talking to people during that kind of
time in their life you're better off
going for more silences and letting them
come and fill that
gap when they're ready not because
you've got them pushed in so
that's the other trick embrace the
silence
i love that i really do and it's
something as an only child
um talking was being able to share
was a rarity and i think that
cultivating that ability to sit with
silence is something that really i've
only developed in my
adult life only recently um but everyone
that's listening knows that right
especially if you're not
you're not thinking sufficiently about
the conversation that you're having
or maybe you're not feeling very
confident around the other person or
just generally not too confident
and you you feel like every second has
to be filled with noise
of some kind because if you're not
talking
maybe that's because you're not
interesting or maybe because it's
because you don't have anything to say
or maybe they'll think that you're not
interesting oh my god what if
what if it's what if it's and you just
garble and sort of babble words out
which you don't need to do
because even on this this show which is
being listened to by other people you
know
million people a month listening to what
is said on this
and some of the best episodes that have
resonated with
people there's a guy called daniel
schmacktenberger who is a
philosopher comes civilization engineer
from
la and some of these weights that he had
during
an episode i did with him were 20
seconds long
20 seconds of pure silence in a podcast
that was only an hour and a half
and he consistently was doing that and
um
the people that enjoyed the episode
really resonated with the silence
so that's you know from someone who is
being fairly heavily rigorously
critiqued online
for the way that they converse i can say
that the conversations in which i've
allowed the silence to sit the most
have had the biggest impact and that's
in a very transactional relationship
with people who can't even interject
they couldn't even contribute if they
wanted to because you know i'm not
listening to them listening to me
um as that was a real that was a real
insight
allowing daniel to have his he's a very
uh considered speaker and i knew that he
was going to have these gaps
so but i could even even when that was
happening um
i i you have it's like vomit it's like
you
have this sort of visceral response and
your shoulders come up yeah it's like
you want to gasp for air you want to say
a thing get the word out when it's quiet
and that's not that's not necessarily
always the best way to deliver
or to allow a conversation to manifest
no uh it absolutely isn't and that's a
great example i go wow i love
that and the other thing too is
that if it is a conversation and you
don't know
the subject matter that well you don't
know what they're talking about
it's actually okay to say that how often
do we try and [ __ ] our way through
something when we really don't know it
uh and i've learned that it's actually
okay to say oh
no i'm sorry i'm not up to speed with
that i don't know that
admit it you know if anything that may
give that person you're talking to
the um the right thing to tell you more
if you want to know more
but sometimes it pays to be honest
you touched on something at the very
beginning saying if you're talking
you're not learning
anything and that is such a
basic obviously such a basic insight
sometimes you synthesize ideas that
already exist in your head while you're
thinking or talking but really it's
unless you're einstein working with like
this unbelievable foundation
um for the most part it's actually best
for your development
to just hear what other people have so
the most
selfish thing you can do from a personal
development perspective
is to selflessly listen yeah
yeah and you'll allow them to imbibe
whatever the other person's got to say
i can't own that quote about um if
you're talking you're not learning
anything new it was the dalai lama that
uh said that not me
i'm just pinching it and paraphrasing it
and
um yeah i think one of the things i was
talking about i sort of said you know if
you
you have to just shut up and and listen
and the the person talking to me said
i don't think the dalai lama would have
used the words shut up and i went now
never mind but
you know it's my version of it it's what
he meant
there was a word that you used in the
book that i haven't heard in years
earwigging
oh my god like if that's not a way to
um make young children
lose a love of listening it's to give it
this
like um
nasty kind of naughty terminology to it
which just makes kids feel like the oh i
shouldn't i
shouldn't be doing that it's even got
its own term like it's
it's literally the way that they learn
it's the way the only way that they're
going to be able to learn
apart from you know seeing what you do
hearing
what you say is next
yeah you feel like you're a bad person
and you're not bad
uh yeah in retrospect i think and
maybe i didn't want to listen to a lot
of the conversations going on with my
female family members
because sadly i think they were just
gossiping when i think about it now
uh the amount of information that i
earwigged and overheard
the majority of it actually wasn't nice
it was gossip about
you know other people either in the
family or in the village
but maybe that is just a small town sort
of syndrome
come on guys take a look at me it's
pretty obvious that i did not grow up in
the time of television
and everything i learned had to come
from radio which i was only allowed to
listen to in very
small occasions because if the cricket
was on then my dad was listening to it
i'd have no problem with the cricket
being the primary source of information
for children growing up i think that
there should be more cricket
at all times uh it's the england the day
that we're recording this
is the third uh in the series of the
yeah what's that is it's the one day or
is that one it is it is that's tonight
it'll be your your morning tomorrow but
my my night
tonight so i've messaged my mate sam
billings who will be listening to this
episode
way way way in the future sammy boy i
need another 100 from you tonight mate
if that's okay
thank you uh and that's good luck but
before we finish up
what have you learned during 2020 that's
reframed
some of the lessons that you pulled out
of stories of hope is there anything
else on top of what we've already talked
about
um it's just how how much i've really
learned more about what the power of a
book
and the power of one person's story and
i'm once again i'm talking about lollies
to affect people and you know
it got born home only a couple of months
ago by one of these amazing emails i've
got and i'm i'm kind of happy to share
it because to me it just
smacked me in the face a 20 year old
young man
wrote to me he lives in milan in italy
and
you know italy got hit and humbled
really really bad
really early on it was you know where it
was all really going down
i'm talking about the pandemic guys and
he wrote to me
oh gosh it would have been i think in
july and he said to me that he lived in
an apartment building in milan
with his parents and his sister
he hadn't left home for months they
weren't allowed out
and all around him friends
family and neighbors were dying he was
hearing about these people he knew
in his apartment building family members
outside who were dying of covert
and he had dinner one night with his
parents and his sister
and he said i told them i've given up
hope we're never going to leave this
apartment alive
his sister went to her room and came out
with my book
and gave it to him he wrote to me 48
hours later
telling me that he hadn't slept he had
read the book and he was now writing to
tell me
that not only has lolly and gita and
silke's survival given him the hope
that he will get out of that apartment
building
but he was going to dedicate the rest of
his life
to all those family friends and
neighbors who did not survive
that's from a 20 year old young man and
milan
so i just continue to be amazed and
overwhelmed
by the bravery of people
being prepared to share
i think it's a very
a not a lost art form but it's a
certainly a missing
a missing piece of people's lives for
them to read
stories of
suffering resilience overcoming
discomfort
um because the lessons that you can
learn from that books like
the tattooist man's search for meaning
um
endurance about uh sir ernest
chackleton's uh
voyage across the the antarctic um
the forgotten highlander by alistair
ercart have you read that
no i haven't you will absolutely adore
it
he was um captured by the japanese in
world war ii one of the scottish
regiment um kept on a death ship
uh basically had dysentery for five
years built a bridge over the river cry
locked in a tin box in
uh heat then um taken to another town
got knocked off his feet by the
aftershock of the
atomic blast from nagasaki everything
that could have happened to this guy
went wrong
and then kept quiet for 60 years very
very similar i think you'll really
really enjoy it
um but i mean that that is a a
sort of a more old story but a recent
one only yesterday tim ferriss
guy that wrote the four-hour work week
and the four-hour chef and the four-hour
body this unbelievably well-known new
multiple times new york times
best-selling author with an amazing
podcast and millions of newsletter
subscribers
he released a podcast um where
he tells the story
um that came back to him during a dmt
experience
about five years ago and it turns out
that between the age of
two and four he was sexually molested
as a child as a baby an infant and
he sits down with his friend who is
um also a trauma survivor and
this is tim [ __ ] ferris right this is
the the guy who has spent
450 podcast episodes talking to the best
performers on the planet
about abstract ideas how can i
utilize the idea of sleep to enhance my
performance so i can get more done in my
day or what's the best way to pulse
um alternate day fasting or whatever it
might be like how can i have more sex
how can i do this than any other but all
of these are abstract ideas
and then tim totally changes everything
there's no musical intro there's no
nothing else
there's no podcast sponsorship and he
says look like this episode
is incredibly personal probably the most
important thing i've ever done in nearly
you know half a thousand episodes
um please like to my friends that are
going to message me when they hear this
like i accept that please accept i'm not
going to necessarily be able to reply
all this stuff
and it's just super heartfelt and he's
spent months working his way up to it
he tells about how he's written this
book that was ready to be published
after his parents
died because he didn't want his parents
to have to live with the guilt of
knowing that they'd let this happen to
him
between the ages of two and four so he's
not to go through all of this stuff and
i'm listening to this podcast
i'm exactly the point that you're making
there which is a single person
story from tim is so much more impactful
than the even the abstract ideas i'm a
lover of knowledge as is everyone that
listens to this show
but jesus christ like that delivery
mechanism the way that he's able to
utilize his own story and obviously the
the subtlety and the detail that you can
only get from having
lived something not just learned it um
is is
one hell of a way to get a point across
and i think
that ties in with what you were just
saying
oh look thank you for referring me to
that i'm going to find that because i
really do want to listen
and i'm going to throw one back at you
it's a book that you don't even know
exists yet because i think it's coming
out in january
and it's called nine lessons for a
remarkable life
and it's written by a london journalist
nadia comani where she's writing it um
with this 100 year old man who lives in
florida
his name is benny or benjamin i
troubles pronouncing eastern european
names but it's
spelt f-e-r-e-n-c-zed
and this this 100 year old man nadia
managed to a bit like me with lolly she
managed to persuade him
i need to tell your story this man's
story should be told in
volumes she writes it in under 200 pages
yeah the the immigrant from transylvania
into new york
the upbringing in the 1920s in new york
put himself through harvard really
incredibly decorated world war ii
soldier in the american army
but because he was a lawyer the american
army
got him to be one of the first
prosecutors of the nuremberg trials
he subsequently was the person that
instigated
the international crimes court now this
man he tells his story with such humor
and beauty and simple every single
word you can relate to even though this
is a man whose brilliance is off the
scale
and is his life is anything but um the
most remarkable one that i've read in a
long long time
so look for a remarkable like yeah nine
lessons for a remarkable life
nadia kamani uh she i think she's with
the guardian or something yeah
i'll put it on the list uh stories of
hope will be linked in the show notes
below of course available on amazon by
the time this goes up
it will be available everywhere uh
anywhere else that you want to send
people any other stuff that they should
check out online
oh no look i think people if you put in
a word just put in a word
google it and and let it take you
wherever you go i do that i love that
and get lost for hours
waste too much time i meant to be
researching my next book but you know i
just i'll find a word oh that'll do
um look just don't never stop learning
that's all i say
and listening i love it thank you so
much for your time heather
absolute pleasure
you